[Music]
this one goes out to all your Co has
that there I want you to know that I
feel your pain and I've been in the same
seat but hopefully one day it would be
better until then this one goes out to
all of y'all Hey Joe what's your boy
[ __ ] Lloyd since the day I've been
limping without an umbrella cord I've
been keeping the score I've been wanting
it more Sam I call me a [ __ ] but not
any [ __ ] more sent by this
relationship has really been one-sided
sapphire I'm sorry but I think you've
been misguided but now it's your turn to
pay me back champ I please bend over and
suck my ass senpai suck my ass will be
together senpai suck my ass it will last
forever sampai suck my ass it's a sweet
sensation stand by suck my
these words are desperation I don't know
if you will like it but I think that you
should try it you don't even have to
suck it that tongue out likely schmucky
if you will like it but I think that you
should try a senpai please just do this
for me some say it tastes like husband
made it all nice and clean down there
for you I shaved it what else do you one
made a doubt and took you forever to
even give me a notice now I'm seriously
considering talking to a proctologist
and over and look at my two circle
figures how they bunch of knights I
don't know go figure just such a let's
minute rate feel a burning sensation get
closer to God in a tight situation
senpai suck my ass will be together Sam
by suck my ass it will last forever Sam
by suck my ass it's a sweet sensation
Sam by suck my ass these words are
desperations and thighs
suck my
are you together Sam bicycie might I say
were last forever
sark my
sweet sensations and I suck my ass this
was the expiration keep fighting falcon
lovers and co highs and maybe one day
we'll get wet with wine until then buy
all my merch I'm serious I it all goes
to me pretty much buy my merch I need to
feed my crack addiction
[Music]